honestly i'm so thrilled that you're all
here we're doing a bond special and
obviously you're all in skyfall we're
going to talk about that before we do
just very good a quick talk about the
last time we saw you was bond uh with
her majesty the olympics
uh like how long was that in the
planning
um quite a long time uh danny boyle came
to visit me on set um
he sat me down he told me what he wanted
to do and i walked out and said
i really thought he was just pulling my
leg so um anyway the whole kind of thing
um you know came about next thing i know
i'm at the palace so because you must
have thought oh i'll agree to it but
it'll never happen you know you can say
well i didn't i mean i thought they
hadn't sort of had the okay from the
palace but apparently apparently they
got that first and then asked me so i
didn't have much choice oh yeah imagine
if you turned it down
wouldn't you do some improv with the
desk
she does it she doesn't probably friday
night
she uh
she kind of invented some stuff to do
she said she asked if she could maybe
pretend to write a letter that so so she
was doing something as i walked in oh
which was i thought was very good there
was a lot of talk about how grumpy she
looked at the actual ceremony
and i have a theory is it because she
didn't understand that for continuity
she'd have to wear that salmon dress
again on the night
do you think she knew that i don't know
i don't know
judy were you asked to be involved in
this because then it would have been no
not at all
not at all i was extremely miffed
and then i saw it all happen i thought
there we are in spite of us all
he never let on he never said a word did
you not say anything nothing did did to
you no no i don't speak english
and traveling around uh roger moore when
i talked to him he talked about how it
didn't matter where he went he could
show up in a village in timbuktu and
people would go james bond james bond
were any of these locations could you go
there and people didn't know that you
were james bond
um
no no um
it is crazy i can't get my head around
it at all i mean i've been in some very
remote locations well you've got to
think there isn't a cinema you don't
have a television how the hell do you
know who i am and yet they do
i think most people too have televisions
i mean
there are very few places like you know
and you know yeah and and because you
are
james bond presumably people treat do
they treat you differently are there
other perks are there downsides i get
treated very very very well and i have
to kind of keep my feet on the ground
otherwise i would really go to my head
more than it's gone to my head already
because i've heard you're saying that uh
drinks just appear it doesn't matter
where you are drinks appear
usually sort of at nine o'clock in the
morning as well and someone will say
[Music]
[Laughter]
now daniel in terms of
being off the part of bond you were
quite reluctant i think to say yes
i was very reluctant i couldn't quite
understand why i was being asked that
was really it was off my radar really i
i mean barbara broccoli
approached me uh to play it and um
i said you're interested well thank you
very much it's very nice but i think you
got the wrong guy
um but she was quite persistent
because it's not like saying yes to
anything else i mean if you walk into a
village in timbuktu some will go james
bond and i have
what does that do to your head i mean
um
it's it's quite disconcerting at first
but i i kind of enjoy it now i think
that i i i'm i'm enjoying making the
films and it's sort of the part of my
life and it's it it's an honor it's it's
a real honor to sort of sort of to do it
so i i kind of take i i take it and
enjoy it i can't there are places i
can't go to but you know i live in new
york and london and people have got more
important things to do they don't really
care that yeah you know they just go
like oh that's just volunteering
do you have to audition for bond
uh yeah i had to do a full day screen
test well it was supposed to be a full
day and halfway through the day i went
to sod this i'm not doing any more
walked off but i mean that was uh well i
mean i'd sort of done it one of the
things you have to do is you have to do
a scene from
from russia with love you know the scene
where he comes in i don't even remember
he comes to the room and uh tatiana
whatever her name is lying naked in bed
and
there's a sort of scene about you know
is that your gun
and then they're filming it from behind
um so i i did that and then i had to
take my shirt off for some reason but
i'm not quite sure
was at the end of the day
did you have to do stunt do you have to
do a forward roll and stuff yeah
so they really make a handstand
but in terms of auditions uh i guess
what's nice is you're auditioning for a
really great job in the beginning you
have to do terrible like commercials
you must have done those though oh yeah
the terrorists i mean it's part of
there was a there was a short period of
my agents here tonight she used to put
me up for commercials and she gave up
because i'd i'd go along to these things
and they'd sort of they'd say things
like
okay i want you to pretend to mow the
lawn it's for me it's for coffee
and we want you to be so happy dancing
to um you're walking on sunshine by
katrina in the waves go
i'm not going to go it's walking on
sunshine
and that would i could never i could
never kill you well a little bird tells
me you still know all the moves
[Applause]
but daniel craig we turned to you
because you started very young as well
yes
you were in school you were the national
youth user now when did you do panto how
old were you when you did panto um
15 14 15 14. now annoyingly we only have
a still but it's still a quality picture
it's a civil quality still this is
daniel craig
see if you can spot which one he is
uh he is one of the ugly sisters
cinderella
can we zoom in on the faces
right or left ladies gentlemen
[Applause]
left
do you know who that is
uh
i think it's um
kelly oh thank
a you time ago richard kelly richard
kelly
hey he's here tonight no he's not
where was that
at school at school production of
cinderella you really went for it didn't
you that's my career right there
commitment ladies and gentlemen i'll
think about when you're making a movie
like this uh daniel you do hurt yourself
a lot like in the in the previous ones
what's happened to you um
i've had my right shoulder reconstructed
i have had
this left knee operated on my right knee
operated on
my thumb hurts
dry scalp
it's very difficult
[Music]